in an unassuming suburb an act of
shocking violence a burning car driven
straight at the home of the town's mayor
in the early hours
he wasn't there but his wife and young
children were and they were forced to
flee his wife suffered a broken leg the
house was ransacked their car destroyed
was today visited by the Prime Minister
Elizabeth Bourne she said she was
shocked by what had happened
the interior ministers dominant who's
led the response to the violence was
another visitor
Mr jeonghorn emerged this afternoon
clearly exhausted and traumatized by his
experience
he walked around his town accepting the
good wishes of locals he told them his
wife wouldn't be walking for three
months
he visited an indoor market that had
been vandalized during the past few days
persevering with his job even though
he's become an unwilling Focus
fearful and scared now lots of people
over the past few days have been victims
of looting and writing but what happened
to him and his family was different it
was a targeted premeditated attack
it was personal
the woman standing by him during this
visit one of the heavyweights of the
mayor's Republican Party
Ching France at the moment and doesn't
understand what is happening what is
what is your message to the watching
World about your nation I am confident
that violence will decrease in the
following days all the troops the forces
are on the field and working on
building a new security in the region
the prosecutor has already visited the
scene of the attack he started an
investigation into attempted murder
this is a comfortable commuter town the
neighbors we met shocked angry and
suddenly anxious
because she told us people are using the
death of Niall as an excuse to do this
but it won't bring him back I think the
family should say something she says to
ask people to stop doing this
France has been shaken profoundly by
violence ever since the death of 17 year
old Niall mazuk and nonte his
grandmother has now spoken appealing for
calm
people who are pillaging stop stop
they're using Nile as a pretext no they
must stop destroying the shops the
schools the buses the mothers take the
buses we take the buses
around the town hall in Lai Lejos there
is now a ring of barricades and razor
wire this place like so many in France
is desperately nervous
Adam Parson Sky News Lai Lejos